all right we are
live on the youtube i'm dave rubin and
we've got another friday panel
extravaganza
for you today we're doing a recap of a
particularly crazy week
with three stories that i don't think
you're going to see
too much of on mainstream media or as my
friend michael malus calls it
corporate media and joining me today are
host of the young heretics podcast and
associate editor
of the american mind spencer clavin
author and former congressman from
the great state of florida trey radel
and author of the new book
panic attack playing politics with
science in the fight against covid19
dr nicole safier welcome to the show
everybody
thanks so much to be here i am i'm glad
to have
the three of you with me first time for
all three of you but i've wanted to talk
to you guys for
for quite some time uh this was a really
bizarre week and i
selected these three stories because
they're mostly gonna be ignored
by mainstream and i think that's
basically the biggest problem we've got
right now that depending on what you
watch
is basically what you decide reality is
so so let's start with
uh what's going on in new york city
right now we put together a little
compilation
of some of the violent attacks in new
york city against the jewish community
and believe me there were many more that
we could have shown and it's still
unfolding at the moment
it's rather depressing but for my
audience that hasn't seen it yet
let's take a look oh
all right so just for a little added
context there uh one of the clips there
was from los angeles
and for those of you that are not
familiar with new york city
the one outside essebago there that's
the upper east side that's where a huge
amount of jewish people live and then
one of the videos where you see them
fighting in the street
was in the diamond district which if you
were ever going to hunt
down jews in new york city you would go
to the diamond district that's where all
the hasidic jews
or many of the hasidic jews work and
this is just burst out onto the streets
in america uh spencer you're you're one
of the few people that doesn't seem to
be afraid to talk about this sort of
stuff
where are we at man i mean those clips
are just
so difficult to watch and it just feels
to me like we are
resurrecting all of the worst evils of
history i mean we've been flirting
with marxism in this country on our
streets now for
years really really for decades and it's
been bursting out in these terribly
violent ways now this just hideous
anti-semitism i mean this is
this is the great ancient evil and it's
happening
all over europe too where of course they
have a long long history with this stuff
they always in the end these people when
they start you know
taking to the streets and making these
racialized arguments you can set your
watch
for how long it's going to take before
they start coming for the jews it's just
it's
there's a deep set pure evil this is
more
to me than just politics and this is the
kind of stuff we were supposed to have
been set free from in america this is
what we do not
do in this country i was just reading
the letter that george washington sent
to the synagogue in rhode island to the
congregation
of jews in rhode island and he says that
made you know he
fondly desires that the children of
abraham will have peace here from all
the other inhabitants
i mean this this is the darkest side of
human history is what's been done
to jews in the past we've seen already
the squad these you know
radical leftists that have infiltrated
our our congress
this is nothing new with them i mean i
i'm old enough to remember when
ilan omar was tweeting it's all about
the benjamins in reference to like jews
buying
political influence essentially now aoc
is out here
condemning the state of israel as if you
know as if they have no right to defend
themselves no right to exist
and the the implication of this is is
simply that jews shouldn't
be around you can make any kind of fancy
argument for it that you want and they
people do they dredge up all this
history
but ultimately at base this is this is
pure animus
i'm also old enough to remember when
about five minutes ago there was an
enormous campaign from all these same
people to hashtag stop asian hate
and i don't want to minimize that i
don't think that you should be asian
people up either
but i i certainly would love to know
where all of that energy is now from cnn
from aoc from iyana presley from the
squad it's just disgusting to me there's
a great article by john podhoretz
uh on on how chuck schumer has you know
spent
all of his time representing himself as
the schomer that which is hebrew that
his
name means guardian right he's the
chamair of the jewish people
nothing from him silence no condemnation
no news stories
they're really showing their hand now on
this stuff and it's it's purely
sickening to me
yeah it's just sort of burst forth
nicole uh
you're also a fox news contributor which
i should have mentioned up top so you're
you work in
new york city sometimes i mean what's
sort of the state
of the city at the moment well no doubt
throughout copenhagen new york city has
turned into a modern day gotham um
but you know and it's interesting that
the media covers black lives matter
protests they were all over the
um the anti-asian hate just as spencer
mentioned
but i'm not seeing the same fanfare and
coverage as we're seeing with the
growing anti-semitism stuff and
you know i personally believe that is
imperative that the united states
steps up and talks about israel which is
the only nation in the mid east that
actually has the same core values as we
do here in the united states
in terms of religious freedom sexual
identity freedom if we don't actually
stand up to show support for israel
that is then we're actually neglecting
our own core values and so i also want
to hear
people come forward and to talk about
that i mean remember last year nancy
pelosi was walking through chinatown at
the beginning
of the pandex saying pandemic saying hey
come on here it's safe
it's great here i mean obviously she
shouldn't have been doing that but why
isn't
where why isn't she doing that now with
the growing anti-semitism you know
that's a great point because pelosi was
not only marching
in chinatown at the beginning of kovid
saying you know come here
but at the same time she was calling
trump racist for calling for a travel
ban
from china and and just for the record
you know even if israel was the most
evil state on the place of the earth
which obviously i do not
believe to be true even if that was true
you can't just attack
people with religious and sectarian
violence in the united states because of
something going on in another country
trey from uh from a guy that was
was in congress for a couple years none
of this surprises me because
this has been brought into congress this
is what aoc and talib
and omar have ushered into congress are
you surprised in a weird way
no this is the democratic party today
and they
are really adding fuel to the fire when
you have these people like johann omar
in reference to what uh anders said on
on the benjamins
the reality of what's going on here is
this is hamas
in manhattan and what's happening in
israel right now
is pretty clear this is not an
israeli-palestinian conflict
this is an israeli hamas conflict
and there's no moral equivalence
whatsoever hamas
targets women and children the israelis
target military installations where by
the way
hamas hides children back to manhattan
this is
these are terror attacks that's exactly
what's going on in manhattan
with what these people are doing how
they're randomly attacking people that
they be
believed to be jewish it's a terror
attack by definition and the last thing
that i'd add to all of this
to again really center on one of the
great at what was one of the greatest
cities in the world new york
is that this is what you get when you
defund the police look i'm
libertarian as hell i believe in
major police reforms i believe that
we're an over-criminalized
society but when you defund the police
and you've got
50 percent or something ridiculous like
that of nypd
retiring early as soon as they can and
they can't even recruit members
to get onto the police force this is
what you get
it's also i mean it's what you get isn't
it when you lock people up for an
indefinite period of time in tiny
new york cubicles right i mean i've i've
been in new york apartments i've lived
in new york apartments i know that
just like in la if you're shut up in
there for you know just
who knows how long really i mean forever
as far as as far as the politicians are
concerned and then suddenly you let all
of that energy
spill out onto the streets and you take
away law enforcement this stuff is a
recipe for
for utter disaster it's it it's
disappointing but it's no surprise at
this point you know we shouldn't even be
shocked
it doesn't even look like the united
states anymore my nephew is a member of
the israeli army he left several years
ago and then he came back to live in new
york city and he said all of a sudden
new york city is having more in similar
to some of the combat zones that he was
in when he was in israel and
you know and that is exactly what
happened when you take away law
enforcement
you know to your point i grew up in or
most of my adult life i was living in
new york city and i grew up in new york
and when i was in new york city a few
weeks ago actually when i did the gut
fell shows the first time i've been
there in a year and a half
it felt like i am legend i kid you not
it felt
like a ghost town and there were just
people wandering around that looked very
shady there were no families out
together no young kids
a lot of barricades a lot of cops and
and here we are but one other thing
on the policing part of this trade that
you brought up is part of this not just
that they've defunded the police and we
know
it is a fact we've covered it on the
show many times that whenever they
defund the police every single
progressive city they've done this
murder and crime has risen every single
one
with no exception but do you think
partly that the ship has sailed in a way
that we
for the last two years the democrats
have basically said violence is okay
get in their face maxine waters this is
what they've said
is okay we've said burning down
buildings is okay and we've said
punching nazis
is okay and in essence they label
everyone a nazi so
is it almost like it's too far now to to
come back in any sensible way
trey yeah i mean when you look at the
summer of 2020
again to kind of piggyback off of what
spencer was saying with regards to
locking people down what the hell do you
expect when you've got people
in their 20s and 30s especially younger
dudes
who just you know are filled with
testosterone and they want to go out and
they want to be social and they want to
meet people they want to
find a job share their resume go out of
their freaking home
and they get locked down it's no wonder
that you have this explosion
of violence because people had quite
frankly lost their damn minds
and not only do you see these calls to
defund the police but they took over
what you're saying
not only is there encouraging of
violence but one of the major problems
in the country today
is that the way that the corporate media
will cover
a republican who says something dumb
understandably offhanded as being oh my
god you need to resign you need to get
out of congress or you need to be
canceled
if you're a private citizen whatever it
is but when someone like maxine waters
directly calls for violence it's
literally not covered in any way shape
or form
and that's that's a real shame yeah that
information
let's go a little further yeah let's go
a little further with that spencer we've
talked about this a lot just that
the mainstream media the corporate press
they have just failed us to the point
that nobody knows what they're talking
about anywhere anymore nobody knows
basic history nobody knows basic facts
and if you watch cnn on an average day
you live in a very different reality
than i do yeah i mean it's it's very
much
to trey's point that this this is
people are watching two different movies
essentially and
we wouldn't all be here if we didn't
believe that the the real movie is
something very different
from what's being shown on on cnn but
people
truly they cannot break the grip of this
spell and they do they come out they lie
and they lie and they lie
and then they don't tell you that they
lied and then afterward they just tell
you something different
and everybody switches the narrative
right i mean this is it it is
truly impossible to penetrate at this
point some of the
fog that they've effectively created
it's one of the reasons why digital
media is so important right it's part of
why this
sort of rebel right-wing conservative
media that has grown up is
a huge part of the solution for the
future
but also i mean there is there's
something key to this too which is the
educational element right this insidious
way
that for decades not just the 1619
project which is the new york times's
you know anti-american screed but even
before that like howard zinn's people's
history of america
they pump this stuff into public schools
they pump this poisonous ideology that
tells you to hate your country
to hate your gender to hate yourself
right and of course
as as we've been saying now like this is
a recipe for getting people
on the streets and they want that i mean
if you go back and you read
nicole hannah jones tweets about this
stuff she's not trying to tell the truth
she's trying to create
a narrative and this sort of thing you
know only ends
one way and as trey was saying this is
the democrat party
they don't even really need to hide it
because they
actually believe this they're being more
and more explicit
and we'll talk about this i'm sure too
when we get to masks you know
they're being more and more explicit
about it soon they won't need to hide it
because they've just indoctrinated so
many people
spencer if only someone had been warning
about what the democrats were becoming
right if only someone had been out there
some guy with a youtube show or
something like that if only that i mean
in essence look
they know they're lying we know they're
lying and they know that we know they're
lying and they keep lying
but that's actually a perfect segue
because i do want to talk about uh
some of the covid stuff and nicole this
is what your new book is about but let's
before i get into the specifics about
pelosi and the hypocrisy
and all that can you just talk a little
bit about what it's been like to report
on covid in in the last year and and how
you've tried
to not spread misinformation in a time
where
nobody trusts the experts anymore i
think the expert class has completely
blown
themselves apart well you know i
approached the last year and
nearly a half now from many different
facets one i'm being a mother of three
boys i'm also a physician working
full-time and then you know i do
writing as well and tell you that um any
information that was coming out
you know we didn't know what to trust
that we were dealing with the last and
forthcoming china
that was really all we could do and just
listen to what was happening with the
whistleblowers
there's been continuing evolving
information some things we were right
about a lot of things we were wrong
about
but it became blatantly obvious right
away that all of a sudden certain
narratives were starting to form and it
was truly the knee-jerk anti-trumpism
which were creating these narratives and
there was creating so much more discord
i mean it is not abnormal to have two
physicians two scientists to disagree on
what a treatment may be
i mean in fact that's how we get some of
the best experimentation
but what the media did with this was
they took it and they ran with it and so
you were either
pro science if you were going with what
said dr fauci was saying but the fact
that
president trump mentioned say like
hydroxychloroquine
all of a sudden if you supported that
you're anti-science but the fact is that
people all over the world had already
been studying hydroxychloroquine
and so i'm not saying it was right or
wrong but the bottom line what big
tech and media did with it to create
this controversy that didn't really
exist it was disgusting and then the
fact that you had
world-renowned medical journals have to
actually retract
some papers because fraudulent data was
used i mean this just took it to another
level and the reason i decided to write
that book was because
i was appalled at how panic and fear was
being instilled into the american people
and although the mantra was to follow
the science they were really doing
anything but following the science in
the beginning yes we didn't have much
science
but i mean by the summer we knew a lot
more about that virus than
we knew in the beginning and it was
honestly it is just unfathomable how
certain restrictions weren't even rolled
back then yeah and you mentioned panic
and fear which we can very easily link
to the previous story which is that if
you keep people locked in their houses
afraid and without jobs and without
social interaction
and drinking more and we know the rates
of suicide and everything else
they might start acting in crazy ways
that might actually happen i just want
to read three data points
for you guys in that tray i'll throw it
to you so right now over 126 million
americans have been fully vaccinated
which is about 38 of the country there's
a 3.1 positivity rate
in the u.s right now which is the lowest
since march of last year according to
john hopkins
and hospitalizations continue to fall by
about
10 weekly according to the cdc uh trey
you know i'm jealous of you man and
every time i'm in florida i see you and
you're tan
and smiling and happy but you're in
florida right now you're in you're in
southwest florida
uh your your governor who i think has
basically
shown us the way out of this lunacy has
saved the state
um pimp out your state i suppose or just
what the correct policies
should have been yeah
hey america welcome to catching up with
florida right now
i'm a huge fan of of governor ron
desantis i love ron
ron uh i'm very proud to call him a
friend i was sworn in
to congress with him uh and we've stayed
in touch over the years
uh look he i mean think about the set of
cojones he had to have at the beginning
of all of this
to look at mainstream media in the face
and say
no i'm reopening i the science shows us
that we can reopen
and we can be safe and that's what the
data has shown us is that we have been
open
for well over a year now and what do you
have you've got
roughly about the same numbers as texas
and california in terms of infection
hospitalization
fatalities the major difference is we're
god and this sounds so cliche
we're free people here we have been able
to to go out to
oh i can't believe i'm saying this we've
been allowed
to go to parks to the beaches to
restaurants
even bars and so i think desantis has
done a hell of a job
in leading us out of this and and look
look one thing i just don't understand
about liberals today the liberals that
i have known through history are sort of
going chronologically 1960s
it was hell no we won't go the
government's bad we don't like their
foreign policy in vietnam
you even go to black power films in the
1970s
and it was stand up to the man you go to
1980s hip-hop two live crew that fought
for free speech
along with ice-t public enemies fight
the power
what i call an american healthy distrust
of government to the 1990s rage against
the machine
f you i won't do what you tell me and
liberals today
they are now the man they're the machine
and it's not resistance it's compliance
everywhere and that scares the hell out
of me in the way that so much of america
i think has just been brainwashed
to sit back and and do what the
government tells them to do
yeah well well said trey although you
know you can brag all you want about
florida but just fyi the local park near
me
a year ago they took down the basketball
hoops because you know most people were
dying while playing basketball during
cobit and just the other day
i was out there driving and they have
put the hoops up so
young people are allowed to shoot hoops
again here in los angeles so brag all
you want
uh spencer but let's talk about the
young element of this i feel like
how old are you am i allowed to ask how
old a guest is you're certainly yeah i'm
i'm 30
30 years 30 okay you're the kid on the
panel or at least the youngest on the
panel
what what has happened here where when
when trey says the word you know freedom
and liberty that is just not a phrase
that the brainwashed masses of young
people
seem to be using they just don't seem to
care or understand the basic reality of
it
no i agree i mean i think it's a really
good point that even
the left in fact in some cases
especially the left of yesteryear
was known for its sort of rebellious i
mean all american
spirit has something of that you know
desire for liberty that don't tread on
me uh
in it and and they hijacked it i think
in two
in two ways one of them has to do with
the education stuff
that i was just talking about if you get
them in the schools if you teach them an
anti-american idea from the beginning
then they grow up and it's really really
hard to get people out of that mindset
but then there's what nicole was talking
about which was the
the expertise issue right this crisis of
of experts
where yeah it's absolutely true that
science
evolves and develops all scholarship
evolves and develops
people change their minds they have
conversations these things are good they
make corrections
all that stuff now in that process you
have these
just arrogant ideologues grabbing
whatever the latest
thing is that happens to be political
politically expedient
they shove it in your face and not only
do they tell you
you have to believe it if you even
question it you're not just wrong
you're evil you're bad right you're
unamerican you're a pariah and it's that
condemnation
that gets into people's hearts right
because nobody wants to be evil right
that's that that deep-seated
shame where they just tell and then you
know they change their opinion and this
is the next thing that you must now
believe
or you're wrong and evil and bad of
course people are rejecting
expertise since that's how they're
behaving but it basically leaves you
with two options right either
you just chuck the whole thing you make
your own way you seek your
own knowledge and the real truth that's
out there
or you obey and and that's what people
are doing
i want nicole to comment on that but
first i want to throw to this video
this is a compilation video it's only
about 45 seconds or so this is nancy
pelosi yesterday talking about how
everyone
should still be wearing masks because
she doesn't want a petri dish and she
doesn't want people up in her face
breathing up in her face frankly i
wouldn't want her with the alcohol
breath in my face but
then it will flash to later in the day
and you're not going to believe what
happens guys you're just not going to
believe it
is this the honor system the honor
system
as to whether somebody has been
vaccinated do you want them breathing in
your face
on the strength of their honor this is
about science
and governance and science and
governance we have a responsibility
to make sure of that the house of the
representatives
chamber is not a petri dish
you're not gonna believe that she didn't
wear the same clothes in
two days or two weeks apart that was the
same day she's in the petri dish
nicole well you know what so you go back
to last summer and you look at what
mayor de blasio did
he put chains around the children's
playground
so children couldn't go play yet there
he was helping to play
paint black lives matter in front of the
trump tower with protesters so
americans are smart they don't blindly
trust the government as obviously they
should not
and so they started catching on that a
lot of the things that were being done
were hypocrisy and so although we were
told to follow the science
uh it wasn't actually happening and
you're still seeing that happen i mean
speaker pelosi she's not even following
the cdc recommendations right now the
white house had live
has lifted the mandates but she has said
nope the mask is going to remain
on the floor until 100 of congress is
vaccinated
to be honest it's really frustrating
when i see this because first of all you
have 75 percent of congress which have
been vaccinated
which means they already have reached
like a vaccine-induced level of herd
immunity
but then you add that to the handful of
people who aren't vaccinated who have
recovered
from covet 19 like congressman massey
who's also protected
because i have just as many studies to
show that his natural immunity is as
protective as speaker pelosi's
vaccine-induced immunity
and you're not it's not anti-vaxx to
question why people are continuing to
neglect
the concept of natural immunity and herd
immunity the goal has never been to get
100 percent of the population vaccinated
the goal has not been to get to zero
cases it's to get to a level of risk
that is acceptable or has
been previously deemed excess acceptable
and we're there now
the emergency is over the pandemic is
not over but the emergency is over and
they need to drop this virtue signaling
drop the hypocrisy and actually start
following the science they are the
self-declared party of science
yeah you know since you mentioned since
you mentioned thomas massey i've quoted
him a couple times this week because he
sent out
several tweets saying that even though
they keep
showing up on television in masks and
they go on this the floor of the house
and masks
that basically no one in the capital in
the buildings meaning security and the
staff
and even the congress people are
actually wearing them behind the scenes
that they're doing it
purely for theater spencer go ahead well
i mean this is
the the hypocrisy that nicole points out
is absolutely disgusting
so brazen but this is another thing that
they're becoming more and more open
about
they're you know they used to try to at
least hide it like at least pelosi had
to get caught at that hair salon
when she was locking everybody down but
now you know the people
now that the cdc is basically saying you
can unmask if you're
if you're vaccinated now that the whole
country is essentially saying we're just
done with this
and now they're writing articles there's
an article in the atlantic just the
other day right
i'm still masking as a form of social
signaling that's
that's why i'm doing it and you see
people on twitter david hogg right i'm
going to wear my mask with people no i'm
not a republican
it was always about this but the cards
are again on the table
all right you have people not losing the
mask because they feel like they're
giving in to president trump if they
don't wear a mask but ultimately
that is the most disgusting show of
disrespect to just science and what we
have accomplished in the last year
take off your mask it is time there's
something
let's actually stick with this for the
rest so we're going to we're going to
put the third story aside and we'll
finish up with this uh trey
i want to let you jump in here but when
i was in florida last time you know
where i go
and i was sitting at a bar uh having a
margarita and i met
and talked to another human being it was
truly extraordinary an 87 year old woman
who was sitting at a bar having a
margarita
by herself okay uh and it was can you
just talk to that that
it's sort of what you were referencing
before but just that these people have
chosen to live
free i just don't think it can be
understated the importance
of someone saying this is my life i will
live how i see fit
yes i'm glad that those people still
exist in our country and there
apparently is a hell of a lot of them
here in florida where even democrats are
giving governor desantis high approval
ratings for the way that he handled
uh this pandemic and i'm glad i know
specifically
uh in the area that i live in here in
southwest florida
it's people who are skeptical
in a very healthy way and who ask
questions about what the federal
government is saying messaging what
they're trying to do
that messaging part i think is really
important to understand
what's happening here we obviously see
all of the hypocrisy from
democrats across the country uh whether
it's gavin newsom
shutting down businesses making
restaurants go into bankruptcy while
fine dining at a michelin rated
restaurant
uh in napa lori lightfoot in chicago go
onto the salon scene with pelosi de
blasio the
the examples go on and on but here's
what's happening and let me
take a shot at republicans here of the
past for a second
do you know where pelosi got the page
that she's running on right now
it's bush cheney what they're doing is
what bush and cheney did in the early
2000s post 9 11.
bush and cheney i believe wholeheartedly
that they utilized
fear in any way that they could to
further
advance their political agendas now look
i think that some of them
were smart and they still protect us in
this country today
but undoubtedly they went overboard but
they were able to do so by instilling
fear in people the way that you instill
fear
is with emotion objects symbols and in
this case
it's a mask and what nancy pelosi is
making a conscious effort to do as well
as governors
and joe biden himself all over the
country
is they're wearing this mask constantly
because they want to keep the level of
fear as high as possible
so they can advance their agenda
legislation it's like this is not any
kind of conspiracy
their legislation in the house and the
senate to spend
trillions of more dollars to reshape the
economy
to spend covered relief which is not
about covert or relief
to spend on infrastructure which is not
about infrastructure it's about
advancing their agenda through fear
and i'm telling you they took a page
from bush cheney in the early 2000s
you know to what got about two minutes
here i i actually want to give nicole
the last word here because i think
ending
ending the the week it's friday uh
helping people get over
fear exactly what trey just said i think
is the most important thing it's what
i've desperately been trying to do on
this show
but but nicole i mean you're also a
radiologist i mean you deal with people
with with
cancer and serious diseases all the time
and i'm sure people that have
you know just undescribable fears
legitimate fears but what would you say
from a medical perspective about the
people
that will not accept that things are
getting better that have been trapped
and are afraid and alone and all of
those things and
where's the hope where's the hope that's
what i want to go out with here so i can
tell you first of all next time i'm
reaching out to trey next book i write
because he essentially just gave the
forward
of my book that is coming out next week
panic attack because that's exactly what
it is
the fear that has been instilled in the
american people during a presidential
year
undoubtedly is not a coincidence and i
want people to look at the data at this
point
it has been a very difficult 15 months
but the emergency truly is over and it
is time to accept that and embrace that
and let go of the fact that we have all
been hunkered down and been told
that if we don't hunker down then we're
going to not only risk our lives but
those around us
we have to truly start looking at the
big picture we have to do what's best
for everyone especially our children
and the fact that they are not allowing
our children
to get back to everyday life right now i
do believe is criminal and at some point
someone's gonna have to be held
accountable
for the damage that is being done the
goal has never been to just control this
virus
unfortunately they did not look at a
country as a whole and some of the
damage is going to
far outlast that of the virus itself
hold them accountable i'm talking about
cuomo i'm talking about newsome i'm
talking about whitmer
and the rest of them and i'm looking at
you trey because you're down there in
florida making me jealous
really something uh guys i thoroughly
enjoyed this i hope you did too i know
that the audience did
and i thank you i'm going to continue
for a few minutes have a great weekend
to the three of you guys
and i'll just talk to you guys for for a
little bit more you know this was
obviously um this has been a very trying
week
you know for i think absolutely
everybody on sort of
all fronts for different reasons i would
say in in a weird sense this has been
the most trying week for me personally
doing this show
because uh this stuff is
personal you know like when i saw those
people in la just get attacked just for
sitting there for going out to dinner
as i said earlier it doesn't matter what
you think about geopolitics it doesn't
matter what you think about the middle
east or what you think about israel or
hamas or any of those things
if we've shifted to the place in the
united states where sectarian violence
is allowed on the streets that sort of
ethno-religious violence
is allowed on the streets or just that
if you don't agree with someone
politically on
literally anything whether it's a
foreign policy in a
uh war halfway across the world or
whether it's abortion
or whether it's the marginal tax rate if
we are have truly got to the place
where violence is allowed politically
then in many
ways the experiment of america that i
always talk about really
is over and this is what i now believe
to be the fight of our generation and i
would say at least for a guy like me it
is the fight of my life and i will fight
with you guys and i i know you know i'm
reading the comments
in in our locals community and i know
you guys are starting to get ready
to fight and i know that many of you are
fighting in your own way and we all
you know not everyone can do it on
youtube not everyone can do it by
by being a police officer but you can do
it by being a citizen who does the right
thing and helping somebody
be better to your neighbor and all of
those things but you know
linking what was happening obviously in
the streets of new york i mean this is
also the city
that i spent most of my adult life i
know those streets i i have a cousin
that lives right by
that bagel shop um and and also i can't
disconnect that
from that what is happening right now
you know these people they're blaming
this okay this is on israel
it doesn't matter what you think about
the geopolitics of it you know there
were pogroms
and holocausts and inquisitions and all
sorts of stuff
before israel right so the stuff that's
happening now in many ways has nothing
to do with israel i think
it's related far more to a horrific
authoritarian marxist movement that is
on the march
in the united states and and the west
and it's like
if they get the united states forget
israel if they get the united states if
this thing really is here
and it has been ushered in by some
really horrific people
in in the progressive caucus and now
it's being it's being sold to us by a 78
year old man that everyone knows has
dementia but they won't talk about it on
cnn
and he's obviously not in charge so i
don't know is it obama in charge i don't
know
i don't know but if this is really where
we're at then then we are at the tail
end of the whole thing
but if we're at the tail end well
wouldn't you want to fight wouldn't you
want to fight and if we're not at the
tail end wouldn't you want to fight
like fight i have watched so many people
so many of my my former colleagues and
friends the
the so-called good liberals just fold
and disappear and have nothing
to say about any of this and if it was
if this was anyone if this was any
innocent person you know
when asian people were being attacked
the media didn't know what to do with it
it's still happening by the way
i mean i just saw more videos of it
yesterday but when asian people are
being attacked the media wasn't quite
sure what to do because they want to
frame everything that it's evil trump
supporters doing all this stuff
and it's not it's not it's just not
you want to talk about a big lie that's
the big lie the
the left has become rabid and racist
and i would argue evil at this point and
i'm sorry to say that
i really am and i wish it wasn't true
and it's in many ways what i spent the
last five years trying to warn people
about
that book right there that's what it's
all about i was trying to say
this is our last chance liberals to do
something but the liberals have failed
we are at the it seemingly at the end of
the liberal order
uh by the way i'm not the only person
talking about this there are some others
and i'm and i'm going to get a bunch of
them on the show over the next
few months to to continue this
discussion but the liberals
have failed and perhaps that is a flaw
in liberalism that just
is but we can now wake up we can now
wake up or we can say we're going to
live in a society that you can beat up
people on the streets and throw bombs at
people in the streets if you don't like
them or if they have some policy you
don't like
and by the way we're going to vote in
elected officials like lori lightfoot in
chicago
who will only be interviewed by people
based on the color of their skin and we
can re-racialize everything and actually
we can burn down
uh the martin luther king jr statue in
washington dc or at least to face it
they don't usually burn these statues it
takes a while to burn statues and these
people don't have a lot of effort to put
into things but we can put graffiti on
it we can
knock that thing over and we can destroy
all our monuments and we can destroy all
our history and we can do all that we
can
we can descend slowly into hell that the
progressives are trying to bring
but there's nobody left there's nobody
left in the democratic party as a matter
of fact
tulsi gabbard who had who i would say
was probably the last
decent democrat she even tweeted this
morning in essence that lori lightfoot
is a racist
and she is except tulsi is really on the
outs with the democrats i'm not saying
that makes her a republican
and it's not it's not for me to say um
but there's nothing left
you think pelosi is going to stand up to
this no
she's not going to they have folded to
the radicals
that's it and and all right in
in this weird time that we live in i
guess everyone has to take a
uh draw a line in the sand and say this
is it i'm not moving anymore so i'm not
moving anymore
and i will fight you [ __ ] and
that's it that's it
uh that was an odd way to end when i'm
trying to give you uh guys some hope but
i
but there is some hope in that um and
and i know there's hope in that there is
hope in that
because america is a promise of this
extraordinary dream and and
just again guys i know i say this all
the time but think about whoever it is
in your family that came to america you
may not even know them
most likely they're not they're long
gone and you may not even be sure in
your own family tree was it your great
grandparents
your great great great grandparents or
long before that or was it grandparents
that you never even knew i mean whatever
it is or whether it's your parents or
whether you're a first generation
immigrant
everyone came here to make it better and
we've done it we've done it and it ain't
perfect but i'm tired of saying that too
because there is nothing
that's perfect but it is time to fight
for this country it is time that is not
racist that is not bigoted everything
they're throwing at us
is they want to destroy it they want to
label all of us and too many of us
folded
too many of us were afraid well it's
here it is literally here
there is violence on the streets which
has been happening now it's
there's sectarian religious violence
they are trying to destroy all of our
institutions and what will you do
well i hope you'll have a great weekend
i actually hope you'll have a great
weekend and not be totally consumed by
this and i hope you'll be with people
you love and friends and i hope you're
gonna eat some good food and maybe
listen to some music and go to the park
and do whatever it is
that you love to do but let's fight
let's fight i'm gonna fight are you
all right that's it